let's say i read an article for the
website it's really popular so now i
know if i write another article like
that it's going to be really popular
well if i do this over and over again
and
and on a weekly basis it won't make a
difference on a monthly basis it won't
make a difference but if i do this for
years
eventually i become irrelevant and i
become irrelevant not only in my
knowledge
and my learning and my development but i
become irrelevant to my audience because
it's the same thing
rehashed over and over again and all i'm
going for is that immediate dopamine hit
so i fell in love with a tweet of yours
from the other month which said
if you're not obsessed with it you'll
never master it being obsessed
with something won't ensure mastery but
not being obsessed
will ensure you won't master it what
have you been obsessed with this year
i've been obsessed with taking care of
my family i mean it's coveted right so
it's obsessed about taking care of all
the people in my life
um work-wise i'm just obsessed with
little details right like the font on
the website and
the instagram backgrounds and you know
people
people think that that's a little bit
obsessive but it's part of the craft
it's part of what we do
writing i'm trying to get better at i'm
obsessed with getting better at writing
and being clear
and being succinct and being relatable
to people
and it helps my clarify my thinking
right because writing is thinking on the
page
and often i discover that through
writing that i really
don't know what i'm talking about and
that's that's a great feeling in a way
it's bad in a way but it's sort of like
the dawning of wisdom right because
you know you you can't learn anything if
you think you already know it and
when you write it down you force
yourself to confront the fact that maybe
you don't know
it as well as you did especially when
you're trying to write it down for an
audience that might not have the context
or
might not be a domain expert in what
you're writing about so you have to
simplify
and simplify doesn't mean that it's
simplistic
it just means that you're using
different words that everybody can
relate to
so you're now you're translating outside
of the domain
in which you might have learned
something you're translating it to a
more relatable domain for everybody else
and i think that that's so powerful for
us to just calibrate our
own knowledge and hone our understanding
of what we know
how do you avoid getting bogged down in
little details thiago forte had a tweet
a couple of months ago talking about how
the highest leverage people that he
knows
most of their work has a rough edged
half-assed quality to it
because perfectionism is a low leverage
activity
how do you avoid restricting the pace at
which you ship work
by focusing on the minutiae
um i think i dabble in the minutia all
the time right so the font
the layout the paragraph spacing all of
that stuff i dabble in it but
it's not important to shipping it
doesn't hold back what we're doing
because that can always be
solved later but when it comes to you
know sometimes you just have to put a
time box around things and it's like i'm
going to give this the best effort i
have in this amount of time
and sometimes you don't and a lot of
that comes from circumstance and
preparation
and a whole bunch of things that you
maybe do or do not control
right like you're you're born into life
you're born into a certain country you
get
genes a lot of this you don't control
your parents you don't control
you're pushed through this and call it
the lucky push right your parents your
socioeconomic status that you grow up
with your friends your school
and you go off into the world and you
have more time to dabble you have more
time to do different things than maybe
somebody who wasn't as lucky
but at some point you take control and
you take control of your own trajectory
and
that is the point where you
start making decisions that really
impact what's going to happen to you in
life and
some people realize that they do and
some people don't and you have to
realize what's core
and what's not to what you're doing too
in your craft right if you're
focusing or obsessed with the details on
something that's not important to what
you do
then you know that's probably not a
productive or high leverage use of time
but if they are
part of the craft you know writing a
sentence it could take all day to write
a sentence but that's part of the craft
of what uh
what i do um when it comes to frenum
street and so those details matter
and they matter a lot and you can
outsource that to other people
and you can be hands-off about it but
eventually then you just become
somebody who's outsourcing everything
and maybe that's what you want
you'll scale really well and but the
internet gives us leverage to begin with
right and so the leverage of the
internet is for us to sort of like
double the number of readers it's no
additional work for me
double the number of listeners to your
podcast or my podcast it's no additional
work for us
and whether you obsess over the font on
your
cover art photography i remember i
listened to a podcast on the way here
today
where you were talking it took you six
months and you woke up in the middle of
the night
and you discovered the name of the
podcast but you had dabbled for six
months so you're obsessively working on
this for six months
and then it hit you in the middle of the
night and i thought that that was like a
key
that's a key relatable story to you how
it all actually works
well from a user good avatar for someone
that does browse
fs.blog it comes across i think
the degree of finesse that the site has
it really is
beautifully and aesthetically put
together another thing that i notice
your tagline changes
seemingly every other time that i go on
whether it's get yourself together or
sort yourself out mastering the best of
what other people have figured out like
all of these are top-notch taglines
and it's obvious to a user at least an
observant user that you are iterating on
this stuff and i think that
you're right when the
marginal cost of increasing the size of
your audience is essentially zero
the selection effect which chooses
whether or not you are going to go from
second in the world to first in the
world or from
40th podcast in your country to 39th to
35th
a lot of the time that is going to come
down to quality
as you get towards the top so i've been
citing the stat a lot recently which is
90
of podcasts don't make it past episode
three and of the 10
that do 90 don't make it past episode 20
so by simply producing 21 podcast
episodes you're in the top one percent
of podcasters on the planet which is a
beautiful power law to see but
of all podcasters that have produced
300 episodes or 500 episodes
what's selecting them as they're further
through the maturation process and i
actually think that's a really
interesting distinction that you're
talking about there
that's probably missed off and twitter
obviously is not perfect for new ones
but
um thiago's tweet misses that which is
that as you get towards the peak of your
craft
those fin fine
tuned points the level of detail and
resolution that you see things with
perhaps does matter it also i think
depends on your particular
goals like what is it you're trying to
achieve i mean i dabble in this stuff
just because i like dabbling in it
i like fonts i like um changing up the
tagline we don't
use any real metrics for uh any of our
page views or anything like that or sign
ups we just want to be the best that we
can be
the best version of ourselves and get
better every day about what we're trying
to do in the craft and
we're about to redesign the whole
website which will come out in the next
sort of like 45 days but the
the idea there is also selection right
so we just don't
we don't want the most readers we just
want the best readers and
same as listeners to the podcast we
don't really we're not going for a
mainstream podcast if we were we'd be
releasing an episode every day
and what we're going for is we we just
want a really good audience who loves
what we do
and that'll take care of itself
that's really interesting really really
interesting point man to
to counteract the consistency and
iteration
addiction um as with everything i think
it is a balance
one thing well eventually you become
irrelevant right so it like just
just work through this with me and this
is my hypothesis so i don't know if it's
correct or not but
let's say i read an article for the
website it's really popular
so now i know if i write another article
like that it's going to be really
popular
well if i do this over and over again
and and on a weekly basis it won't make
a difference on a monthly basis it won't
make a difference but if i do this for
years
eventually i become irrelevant
and i become irrelevant not only in my
knowledge and my learning and my
development but i become irrelevant to
my audience because it's the same thing
rehashed over and over again and all i'm
going for is that immediate dopamine hit
of what the audience wants and i know
it's popular because the metrics tell me
it's popular
same as with podcasts right big name
guests probably get more downloads than
people that nobody's ever heard of
before but if you only do big name
guests
then you're not having fun as a host
you're not getting to explore the
subjects you want to explore
it becomes a business instead of a craft
and that's fine because uh
you can look at it as a business that's
why i said it depends on your goals and
and what you're trying to achieve when
you say
the best that we can be is what you're
optimizing for
how are you what are the ways that
you're adjudicating that
well a we have to make a living right we
got payroll we got to pay people so we
do need to generate some sort of income
off what we do
um but we also want to give back to the
world so part of what we're trying to do
is equalize opportunity
in the world not outcomes i don't
believe in equal outcomes i do believe
in equal opportunity
and we don't have it so what we're
trying to do is popularize thinking
mental models
critical thinking and sort of give
people a broader education
than what they got in school because we
specialize so early and so the best
version of that means
it's just increasingly relatable to
other people it means we're creating
timeless content we're talking about
timeless things
we've been i you know i've been blogging
since 2009
and honestly you should be able to go
look at any article from 2010
2011 2012 2013 and it should still be
relevant today
and that's the goal that we have for
ourselves and that's independent of sort
of page views now with that said
you know we also you we need feedback
and the feedback comes from
touching people um and by touching them
i mean interacting with
people who read your website not
physically touching them because we're
all supposed to be physically distant
right now
but we go to events we talk to people we
hop on the phone with readers
we have an engaging learning community
where people give us feedback about what
we're doing
and touching that medium is really
important because if you don't touch the
medium you get out of touch
and so we have to know that what we're
doing is relevant for the people that
we're trying to do it for
so yes we're trying to do it for
ourselves but we're also trying to do it
for other people and if we're writing in
a way that doesn't resonate with other
people
that the examples don't resonate the
theories are too far out there
the prescriptions are not applicable
then we're not doing our job in the way
that we want to be doing it and it's not
going to help us
accomplish our goals that's an
interesting thing to do with anyone
that's a creator or has goals online
the map and territory metal model is a
perfect example of this right that you
have a dashboard which is
a rough-hewn set of statistics but it
is a proxy for telling you the things
that you might actually be optimizing
for
presumably page views must at least in
some part be
aligned with popularity because the more
popular it is the more people see it but
why is it popular
is it just racing to the bottom of the
brain exactly and then what's that
what's that effect where when a measure
seeks to become the measure the outcome
itself
oh i think i know it i don't remember
it's not the parking system it's not
parkinson's law
people are going to be screaming at me
anyway that thing but when you optimize
for the outcome
of the measure as opposed to the actual
outcome itself yeah um
well that's what we do at work all these
kpis right we're optimizing for
but if you the map is not the
territory's a perfect mental model
that's exactly what we were talking
about in this sense
we get so far distant from what we're
actually doing in the feedback of it
we're operating based on a map and we're
not in touch with the territory so when
the territory changes
we don't know that the territory has
changed because it takes a while for the
map to update
we do this in organizations if you run a
team and you have
let's say multiple managers below you
everything gets filtered
we learned this in kindergarten right
one one way we learned this is sort of
how information gets filtered to us so
in an organization we distill it into a
dashboard we have metrics we have all
these things
and if you're doing it that way if
you're operating that way your job
as a manager your job as a leader is to
touch
touch the territory on a regular basis
how's the morale with people are these
still the right metrics what's behind
the scenes with these metrics
is the goal post changing is the way
that we calculate them changing
are they still the relevant metrics so
your job changes from just sort of
managing to being active
and then it becomes i need to be active
touching the territory in kindergarten
we do the
the telephone tag game right you sit in
a circle i don't know we do this in
canada
you sit in a circle one person says a
sentence you go around the circle by the
time it gets back to the person you
started
it sounds nothing like and everybody
just changed one word
well that happens in organizations right
so if you're the ceo of an organization
and somebody who's really close to the
problem say you work in manufacturing
and they're on the floor
they know exactly what the problem is
but and they pass that up
but as that gets passed up layer of
layer of management everybody has their
own
slight tweak on it different motivations
different incentives to say something
different
and the information gets lost in the
process and that's why it's so important
that we actually touch the territory and
one way that we've done that or
popularized that is sort of management
by walking around
i hate that term but what really goes on
with management by walking around
is you're getting away from the map and
you're touching the territory to make
sure that territory still relates to the
map
and if you think about it that way it
makes all the sense in the world because
you're not just walking around to say hi
i remember
i used to work with people who did that
they would just walk by and they'd be
like hi
and you talk you know they read this
book and they're like oh that's
management by walking around he saw all
of his employees today and
you know went back to their office and
but that's not what it means it means
you need to be connected to people
connected to the people you work with
connected to their work you need to
understand it at some level
and if you want to solve problems you
really need to get as close to the
problem as possible because nobody
understands that problem
at least the individual context of that
problem
like the person closest to it you might
have a global context that you can add
to it which might change the solution to
it
but you really need to talk to the
people who are closest to the problem if
you want to solve it the interesting
challenge there
online especially for content creators
is that you're inherently buffered
away from the problem you're away from
the map and the territory itself as well
right like everything has got distance
between you
and it have you got any advice about how
people can
import well not only is there a ton of
distance there's a ton of noise
right and that becomes hard because now
you have to pick the signal from the
noise so who's actually telling me
something that matters versus don't i
don't know about you
but i get a negative call i'll get a
thousand positive comments i'll get one
negative comment and it's that one
negative comment that like
really hits me uh and i can't let it go
and so
touching the territory is sort of like
okay are there i'll give you a great
example of something
we messed up uh we released an audio
book called the great metal models
volume one
and i did the narration for that and we
did it with a studio that had never done
narration before and a whole bunch of
other things anyway
the narration sucked uh and it's totally
on me
but when i get the feedback from it the
first bit of feedback is sort of like
okay well one person said that
now that i'm not gonna like it bothers
me but it doesn't carry a lot of weight
but
as more and more people and you start to
get a cohort of people and
it doesn't have to be a large cohort but
it's enough people
that for the second volume we switch
narrators we get a different narrator um
so it's sort of like okay we got
feedback on it
the feedback made sense and it was it
wasn't consistent but it was enough
feedback to be
relevant and statistically large so okay
at that point
now the world's telling us something we
have a choice do we adapt to
what the world is saying or do we
continue to believe that
they're wrong and i'm right and the
narration is fine
and it's like well no i don't have any
ego in this i don't really need to be
the narrator there's no reason for me to
be the narrator
um and so it's changed the narrator
right and it's it's that sort of simple
but it's really hard when the world
gives us feedback like that
when the map or the territory is is
changing
that to change the map especially if we
created the map
and that becomes like a really
interesting nuance to this is because
now
uh not only is the mount if you created
the map it's easy for me to be like oh
the map's wrong change it but if i
created the map it's totally different
problem
it's much harder for me to to go back
and say oh man this thing i created i
spent maybe thousands of hours on
that's wrong i got to do it differently
and i got to think differently about it
and i think that
the phrase that we we use internally is
outcome over ego
and it's about putting the outcome first
and your ego second
so often what we do in organizations and
what we do in life is we put our ego
first and the outcome second
and a great example of that is sort of
knowledge workers where
we go to work we're a knowledge worker
we get paid for knowledge right that's
inherent in
the title of what we're doing so if
we're not right what are we
and that means we're wrong and we can't
be wrong because we're getting paid to
be a knowledge worker so
and then what happens is you start
distorting reality through the lens of
you being right so it's not about
who has the best idea or who gets us to
the best outcome it's about me
being right and we never work
so hard in life as we do to prove
ourselves right even when we're wrong
we will go to the ends of the earth to
be right we'll discount evidence we'll
ignore other people we will prove them
wrong we'll get a chip on our shoulder
about it we'll be the i told you so
person we'll be
you know not our best selves and so one
way to do this and creators get this all
the time right so if you think about the
creator economy and
and sort of i wouldn't say thought
leaders as much but people who create
things for a living and rely on people
buying them
it's different right you're in a
different frame of mind because you're
getting constant feedback that's sold
that didn't sell
people are telling you you're getting a
lot more nuances along the way
you want to be right but the world will
give you very clear evidence that you
were wrong
and you have two choices you won't last
long in this business if you don't adapt
and you don't
same as organizations if you don't adapt
to the reality as it changes
um or as you learn more about it and
it's unchanging
then you're going to be facing a big
problem
an additional challenge which is faced
online are the
incentives of bad actors because as
you've identified
comment sections can be a pretty ugly
place to be and you don't know whether
this person's commenting from a place of
good faith
is there some sort of selection effect
that this particular medium
or demographic or time of day or content
or guest or
whatever is selecting for which is
skewing the kind of feedback that i'm
getting
i'm not able to run this through the
filters that i would be able to so yes i
agree
the online content creator has
more immediate feedback from the market
and they are in some ways
closer but in other ways they're further
away
because they have a lot more noise to
sift through
great way to put it you had a tweet as
well talking about ego you had a tweet
that said
don't let the victories go to your head
or the defeats go to your heart
how can people detect when their ego is
serving them and when it's deceiving
them
uh when you just get too high on
yourself in that sense right like when
you're
you sort of have a win and i had a
friend who inspired this
i definitely won't mention their name
and hopefully they don't listen to this
podcast but
uh they made a lot of money on bitcoin
and it sort of
you know it went to their head and by
went to their head
it it made them think that they were a
great investor
and i think that's going to lose them a
lot of money in the future
there is no way that that person is
going to work out who that is because
there are about a hundred
thousand people just in america that
are in that position yeah well i only
have a couple of friends so
in that position so it's not it's not
hard for them to discern who that is but
uh i think that you know we just we get
overconfident in our abilities
and a dose of humility but it's the same
for the opposite
right like uh you're not a bad person or
you know you don't need to give up if
you write a tweet
not a thousand people like it or you
know that
you can't let that affect your drive and
your motivation
and you also can't get overconfident in
your ability
if you you need to distinguish between
when you got lucky and when you're good
and if you're good you can't be
complacent because the world won't let
you be complacent that's what i mean by
letting it get to your head
if getting to your head means it affects
your drive it affects your
um what you do and what you take on
then it's a problem and i think the same
on the the opposite end right your heart
is where your drive comes from
and not everything is going to go the
way you want it to i mean nobody would
have predicted the last year but we've
all come through this pretty
tough year together and for some people
it's really got to them it's got to
their heart and
it's sort of depressing and demotivating
and i think that
it's not it's trying not to allow that
and you control your circumstance or not
your circumstances but you control how
you respond to your circumstances and
what's happening
and so if you have a good day that's
great you had a good day and if you have
a bad day that's great you had a bad day
and what i try to teach my kids is
they win or they learn right and so if
you're in school you're playing a video
game
maybe you lose it's what did you learn
right that's a win
you can look at this totally differently
don't let it affect how you
how motivated you are to play or where
you go from here
don't let it affect your heart just help
it
one of the things that help you i guess
yeah one of the things i've been
thinking about a lot is how athletes
deal with situations
i've been increasing i played sports as
a kid throughout all my childhoods and
i'm a big fan of watching sports as well
only recently have i realized just how
beautiful of a
environment for high performers it
creates
it's bounded it's got very easy to
quantify
objective metrics of success and failure
there are slow
um contributing factors that you can get
to in terms of your speed and your
stamina and your power and your outputs
and
you can run drills which you then apply
so you can kind of do a dry run of the
thing that you're going to
me and you haven't done a dress
rehearsal of this podcast before we come
on here and then do it right so i'll say
this and then you say that and then yeah
we'll wait for a bit
so i i've just been fascinated by seeing
that
and one of the problems one of the
reasons i think that people become
disheartened
with work is that there is such a myriad
of reasons
about why this could have gone well why
this could have gone badly
what contributed to my preparation or
lack thereof was it the sleep last night
was it the diet was it the argument with
the misses in the morning
and um yeah i think athletes those that
are listening
you have a very you're blessed with a a
very particular
environment within which you can deploy
your excellence but it's also super
competitive right
it's you know you miss a step you might
be off the team and
and athletes are a great example of not
letting victories get to your head or
defeats get to your heart
you know if michael jordan for example
playing basketball missed a shot and let
that affect his drive
um then he wouldn't be the michael
jordan we knew and if he
you know won and it went to his head he
wouldn't have worked as hard in the
offseason to get back there next year
and so like i think athletes are a pure
sort of manifestation of that but we're
we're knowledge athletes in a lot of
ways right
it's just as competitive uh at least if
you're a competitive type person
and you know slight nuances because of
leverage can make a huge difference
in your ability to not only deliver for
the organization but deliver on you
your goals and what you want to get out
of life and i think it's important that
we're
we're not complacent we don't coast and
we we sort of keep moving forward and
what do we need to do that well
we can't let everything go to our head
and we can't let it affect our drive
so that's where that came from do you
think it's possible to have a desire to
improve that doesn't come from a place
of insufficiency this is something i've
been thinking about
a lot recently people many people
that want more out of life i think are
doing it from a place of a fear that
they're not enough
as opposed to a desire to do more well i
can only speak
in my personal circumstances i would
word it as pleased but not satisfied i
mean
i'm super happy with my life and where
things are
does that mean that it can't be better
that i can't do more for other people
that i can't
live a more meaningful fulfilling life
no not at all do i have to discover what
those things are yeah that's part of
life
but i don't think for me it comes from a
place of insufficiency
and i think you know we all have drive
for different reasons
mine is a chip on my shoulder you know
from being a kid and told that i
couldn't do anything being told that
i sucked at school and i'd be lucky to
pass high school and
all of those things and drive everybody
has their own drive
and if your drive comes from
insufficiency i would sort of
encourage people to change that story
like let other people
become the fuel for your fire but you
choose how that fire burns
and if it's in insufficiency it's not a
i don't think it's a healthy fire
and i don't think it's going to burn
really long and really hot i think you
need to turn that into
a different sort of story that you tell
yourself which is i am enough i'm enough
and if people don't think i'm enough
then maybe i have the wrong people in my
life
and i think that it's really hard to get
rid of people in your life because
you're scared
um but that's a much better choice than
living your life like that for the rest
of your life where you feel like you're
not enough you feel insufficient
and i bet you i bet you if you did
research you go talk
go to an actually this would be a great
example like go to
a retirement home or something and just
volunteer time there and talk to people
and i bet you they will all have felt
those things at various points in their
life but now they'll be able to give you
perspective
on what they would change what they
would do differently and i bet you
they'd delete people from their lives a
lot quicker who made them feel that way
yeah man it's so strange the way that
our formative years
when we grow up it just embeds into the
substrate of who we are right and then
you spend
you know you've got 10 years of
imprinting and then
70 years of deprogramming it's kind of
neat
funny yeah and you don't have
perspective right you only see sort of
like so for
in the mental model context of
relativity right and so the way that we
learn relativity and i'll relate this
back to the story in a second is
grade 9 physics you're on a train you're
holding a ball the train is moving 60
miles an hour you're holding the ball
how fast is the ball moving well
relative to you
the ball's not moving at all a casual
observer it's moving 60 miles an hour as
the train passes by
and as as you're listening to this if
you're sitting and you're not in a car
you could say how fast are you moving
and you feel like i'm not moving at all
you know you're stationary i'm
stationary but if we put ourselves on
the sun
we're moving at like 18 000 miles an
hour right all of a sudden and
so this perspective matters and i think
we we often get caught in our immediate
perspective and we're blind to the how
do we
actually put that in perspective of life
perspective of meaning and so
talking to somebody who's older or
imagining yourself being older is a
great way to get out of your current
perspective
and put whatever's happening in a
greater broader perspective
you probably don't want to wake up at 90
having lived this life where you feel
inefficient
or insufficient to other people you
that is not the way that you want to
live and you can imagine yourself at 90
and you can really work backwards and
see that that's the case
or you can sort of go talk to somebody
who is 90 about this thing and they'll
put it in perspective for you
in their their way right with their
wisdom
of having lived a much longer life
starting with the end in mind is such a
powerful
mental model to do but it's so difficult
to hold on to man you get caught up in
the urgent
right the day-to-day you've got to reply
to this email and
pick the kids up where you i don't you
do and you know
all the all the different [ __ ] that
we've got to do right and it's very very
easy
death by a thousand cuts to slowly be
skewed
off your trajectory of where you were
going and you can end up doing stuff
that
in no way contributes to what it is that
you want yeah i am
something that i i heard you mention on
rich rolls show was that you guys take
the two months off every
every summer are you guys still doing
that yeah totally so
uh things start winding down june 1st
and uh
they we we go to four day weeks and then
this year we gave august off to
everybody
uh in the entire company and i mean i
take july and
most of july and august off and that
helps balance in perspective but going
back to what you said yeah you get
caught up in the minutia but the problem
is we prioritize the minutia
and you should be giving yourself the
best hour of the day either for
learning or the most valuable thing that
you're contributing to the the company
and how do you do that because people
always say well i don't have time to do
that it's like no you don't have time
not to do that
the way to do it is you book it in your
calendar but you don't book it for
tomorrow because you look at your
calendar for the next month your book's
solid
of course everybody's books sell it but
you go two months out and all of a
sudden you see a 9 a.m slot
on a monday well now you book every
monday at 9am and you book a meeting
with yourself and then you book tuesday
wednesday and ideally you get up to five
days a week
you just go out as far as you need to do
to do this and then what'll happen is
you'll wake up in october
and the first 90 minutes of every day at
work
you know is your time it's your time to
learn
it's your time to work on the most
important thing it's your time to
to sort of make decisions but the
problem is we look at our calendar next
week and we're like there's no way i can
do that and it's well of course
like because you're booked solid and
that's you know you're making choices
too being book solid but
i would encourage you to go way far out
book it now
make it consistent make it repeatable
and then you never have to find time and
what ends up happening is all this
minutia that doesn't really matter
gets crammed into the last hour of the
day
and then you're really good at
prioritizing in the last hour of the day
you're terrible
at the start of the day at the start of
the day anybody can usurp your time
they send you an email you go on this
wild goose chase but the last hour of
the day you're like man i gotta get home
uh i got a date or i gotta get my kids
or
i just wanna leave the office and so now
it's like oh i don't need to do that and
then the other thing that you learn
and this is the lesson i i sort of i
went to one of my bosses one day
and she said you know balls bounce for a
reason but most balls won't bounce
and so what's important at 8 am unless
it's really an emergency
often by 4 p.m that problem has already
been solved
so this thing so you're actually going
to save a ton of time when you start
pushing out
a lot of the stuff to the end of the day
and the other thing that i've noticed in
organizations and
and i don't know if this relates to some
of your listeners or not but
uh there's people who who hog your time
and by hog it i mean they'll send out a
draft presentation
and you know it's a shitty draft and
they'll be like what do you think of
this and you'll spend like an hour
fixing it and what they've really done
is they've outsourced their job
to you and you need to have standards
and your standard is
uh you know is this the best you can do
and they'll never say yes
they'll be like i'm looking for comments
well send it to me when it's the best
you can do and then i'll take a look at
it right
and that can be your standard and then
people will stop annoying you with that
and i think it's really powerful uh way
to get out of all of this because i you
know i used to get consumed but i worked
for
an intelligence agency right which is in
still in many ways government
and you get consumed by this stuff and
it's like well that's not why i signed
up that's not what i want to do
none of this is actually productive how
do you
structure your days or your weeks to be
productive have you got that 90 minutes
first thing in the morning
uh i have three hours so from 9 to 12 i
don't book any meetings
um so every morning every day with very
few exceptions
i know i don't have to find time to do
what i want to do and what i want to do
can be
spend time with the kids go for a bike
ride what i want to do can be
write a book what i want to do can be
whatever is the most important thing for
me in that moment it could be sleep in
right but i never have to find the time
the problem is we're always looking for
time for the most important thing for us
and we need to change our the way that
we think about it and give ourselves
we get one life right you could die
tomorrow i could die tomorrow
i don't want to live that life knowing
that i just got caught up in email and
part of that means you know about
three years ago i went through this
crisis where i used to
answer every email i got and i was like
it just takes
like three four hours a day answering
email and i'm like this i can't do this
anymore
and it's really
you know at first it's really hard for
me because again staying in touch with
the medium
being connected to people so now i i
read or at least skim
every email but i don't reply and i
really just don't reply to a lot of
things right like i won't reply to
group threads at work unless i have
something of value to add
and my baseline for contributing
in meetings uh on emails and all of that
doesn't start from here i'm going to
share what i know with you it starts
from what's my unique take on this
particular problem
do i have something that you probably
won't see can i see a blind spot that
you're missing
what do i know about this problem that
you don't already know and so often
what consumes time at work two things
one we're telling people what they
already knew because we're
signaling that we did work we're
signaling that we're a knowledge worker
we're signaling we're smart
but we're effectively just paraphrasing
something that everybody already knows
that's a huge waste of time
and we get stuck in this sort of
rut where we're just telling people what
they already know so to change that
around
at your next meeting instead of saying
what do you think of xyz say
does anybody change the value of
signaling to signaling something that
not everybody knows what's your unique
view into this problem
and then reward people with that sort of
signaling right so now you're giving us
you're contributing information to the
problem
instead of just telling us what we need
to know and if you're saying something
that we already know
it's easy to oh we already know that
like that's established or
um you know you can you can sort of help
people move to this point and it'll take
a couple weeks for it to work its way
through but
it's really effective at gathering
information and gathering high quality
information because what you're really
trying to identify is
what are our blind spots and the other
thing that consumes people at work
is poor decisions and so we get rushed
into this culture where
i think we've all been there you get
this briefing it's like 70 pages either
a
powerpoint presentation or you know a
big document with a lot of research
you read the executive summary because
you have no time you read it on the way
to the meeting
and then you you signal that you did the
work by you know paraphrasing the
executive
summary nobody's actually looked at the
data nobody understands the territory
you've only looked at the map
and then you make a decision based on
that and the problem with that is that
decision comes about to bite you but it
doesn't bite you right away
it'll bite you in three to four months
and then the other way that
we you'd think that that would be great
feedback for us
to make better decisions but it's not
because
there's a lot of people between us and
the implementation so now we blame
execution
wasn't the decision we made it was the
execution right because it's so easy to
wash our hands of any
absolve ourself of any responsibility
but in reality
poor initial decisions consume a ton of
time at work
and what we're really doing with a lot
of our time is fixing
our own mistakes we don't want to admit
it to ourselves but that could be a
communication mistake it could be a
mistake in the decisions you made it can
be a mistake
and then that consumes a ton of our time
man i am i don't
think how much time has been saved and
then re-lost
over the last year with this switched
virtual
so all of the meetings that were
potentially used i saw this amazing meme
i think it was rory sutherland that that
shared it
where he said it's this guy looking and
he can't believe it he's sort of staring
into his hands
and he said all of those meetings really
could have just been video calls
and it's like that's like the synopsis
of of 20 20
20 20. a lot of those uh video calls
could have been emails and a lot of
those emails could have been taxed and a
lot of those texts like
shouldn't exist it didn't need to be
sent yeah
here's another thing that i've been
thinking about i wanted to get your
thoughts on
is there a point where we should stop
focusing on exploring
and learning skills that we want to
acquire and instead focusing on
exploiting the ones that we have
this kind of growth treadmill people
constantly looking for
new acquiring i think this probably ties
in a little bit to the place of
insufficiency thing i need
more i need to know more as opposed to
just focusing on exploiting and really
getting stuck into the work
two thoughts there i don't i think
that's a false duality i don't think
it's an either or you should always be
learning and you should always be using
the knowledge that you learn
i think what you're you're talking about
in a broader sense is
we're channel surfing life right and in
a lot of ways
we're we have a poverty of commitment
because there's so many options we don't
want to commit to any one option because
the minute we commit it locks us down
into something and we start to get
feedback and maybe we're not good
and you know we're a beginner and it's
hard so we just
we we changed the channel remember when
you're a kid and you just like flick
flick flick we we do this with
netflix now like the endless browsing
you don't actually end up watching
things
you know it's 45 minutes later and
you've just sort of previewed all these
shows
but in life uh what we really value and
i i was reading about this a little bit
recently like what we really value
anybody that we hold up to be um
amazing or do incredible things they've
all committed they've all gone
all all in on one particular idea
whether it be
you know elon musk or jeff bezos or
whoever it doesn't really matter
right uh any athlete same thing right
they've gone
all in on what they're doing and so we
really value it
in other people but we're scared to
commit to something for ourselves and
so we endlessly like channel surf we're
always looking for the new latest hack
we're always looking for the
the new way to do things when you know
in reality
uh it's the boring things that actually
lead to the outcomes right michael
jordan the best basketball player
in the world and he's just top of mind
because i've been reading about him
recently first pra first pass that he
would practice at
every practice was a chess pass well he
learned how to do a chess pass when he
was like five
it is literally the most basic pass in
basketball and you have somebody at the
pinnacle of their career
working on their chest paths and you
know that's all in that's commitment to
one thing
and that comes with consequences it
comes with costs and
it might mean that we're wrong and i
think that's what we're really scared of
and so if we endlessly channel surf
we're never going to be wrong but we're
never
gonna be right either and i think that
that's really interesting
from uh you need to decide how you live
your life
not let other people tell you how you
live your life you need to decide what's
meaningful for you
you need to decide what you're going to
commit to what's worth committing to and
what's not but if the answer is
nothing's worth committing to then the
problem isn't
the options available to you the problem
is you
i love that i was reading the power of
marginal by paul graham it's quite an
old blog post now okay he says the more
successful people become
the more heat they get if they screw up
or even seem to screw up
in this respect as in many others the
eminent are prisoners of their own
success
as your platform grows and fs.blog gets
more and more renown do you sense this
at all do you
have any strategies that avoid
becoming too concerned about the success
and about what comes with that
uh well the success isn't really about
me we call i mean i called it fs.blog
for a reason
yeah exactly yeah well definitely not
that right because it's not
and then our tagline the one that sticks
all the time
is mastering the best of what other
people have figured out and so
i don't have the answers i mean nothing
i've come up with nothing original in my
life and so
i don't i think that's the popularity
is for the website the popularity is for
the concept the popularity is for
learning the popularity isn't
uh unpopular uh and i don't i don't see
it that way
i mean i don't um i definitely don't
think of myself as that way
and you know i was talking
with my buddy james claire about this
the other day he
he had this wonderful phrase where he's
like i want to be the most well-known
person that nobody recognizes
and i thought that that was really
interesting right so uh not being sort
of
recognized or approached and having a
big audience but
well and the question is like why do you
want a big audience is it for a big
impact
or is it because you want a big audience
because that's your your fast car
or that's your your sort of internal ego
driving you and i think
you know for me i see farnum street as a
project that outlives me
and so i'm just a caretaker or curator
at this point in time and there'll be
another
person behind me who does the same thing
under the same brand with the same
audience or a new audience
but it just continues because what we're
talking about doesn't
doesn't change what's valuable learning
we might have to recontextualize some of
the lessons for today's day and time but
we'll still be talking about the same
issues
and so i don't view the website as like
my lifetime i view it as something that
surpasses me
something that lives in infamy and
hopefully just goes on forever
right and but it's not about shane it's
not about me
it's not about anything that i do i'm
just the temporary steward of this
you're sounding a lot like the dread
pirate roberts here it's like ross
oldbridge
meets uh meets shane parish there's a
quote from my buddy rob henderson who
says
you want everyone to know your name and
no one to know your face
oh yeah that's inch i'll pass that on by
james yeah that's really interesting
i think rory's identified the optimal
level of fame as
sometimes having someone come up to you
in the airport
that was his definition of the optimal
level of fame
well yeah i think so but like on the
internet it's different right because
now people can attack
you and people can make up stories about
you and
uh they can you know try to take you
down a peg
even if they don't know you they've
never met you the stories are false
uh you know they can carry their own
weight i think that you know there's a
bit of a different world now where
you know you used to be able to to sort
of um that one crazy person if there
there was one could sort of like yell in
a in an airport or theater
and cause a scene but the number of
people impacted are you know
i don't know tens and now it's thousands
and
possibly millions and i think that the
you know the world is different now and
we haven't quite
adjusted to what that means and we'll
have to find some way to do that because
we don't want to
we don't want to prevent people um from
sharing their thoughts and you mentioned
paul graham's essay polygram is a
great example of somebody who's uh you
know profound
thinker great sas great writer
and we we don't want to discourage uh
the next paul graham because they don't
want
um and so i think anonymity is gonna be
a big thing and i think that that's
gonna
whether it's enabled by the blockchain
or something else i think that
people want to have an identity that's
online that might be detached
from them as a person and everybody
online just
we already do this when you think about
it we because we just show part of
ourself online
you don't see my whole life um you see
sort of what i'm thinking about you
don't see my time with my kids you don't
see any of it
so we just see one part of people so if
we detach
uh people's identities from their their
self and we put them out there as
here's one part of me i'm gonna put that
out there and maybe it'll be
controversial and
that'll be good because now we can start
playing with ideas a bit more again
right we've
we've stopped that because if you're um
fairly popular
on any platform you don't want to do
anything too controversial
and so you might not say what you
actually think but that
that in itself is suppressing ideas
being shared
suppressing freedom of speech
suppressing other people benefiting from
that
you might be wrong and you get feedback
that you're wrong right but now you
don't want to put it out because you're
too big there's too much at risk there's
loss aversion about what
you're doing and i think that that we
need to fix that because we want the
best ideas we want them to circulate we
want people to talk freely
and i don't mean that in any political
sense i just mean it in sharing ideas
technology moving the world forward
equalizing opportunity
amongst everybody so we all start with a
level playing field
not that we end up with a level playing
field but we start with a more level
playing field
i'm still undecided about the future of
the anonymous
creator economy george mack mutual
friend
is super bullish on it adamant that
that's going to be the future
i appreciate given your background and
how the blog
started that it makes a ton of sense the
one
flying the ointment that i see is that
people follow people they don't follow
things traditionally you know you think
cristiano ronaldo has
40 million followers real madrid has 16
million elon musk has doubled the amount
that any of his companies do all added
together
because we require that maybe the
anonymity will permit people to get
around that perhaps we'll get used to
the persona following the persona not
the person
um but i'm not sure and that'll be but i
i mean farnum street started
as an anonymous blog and it would have
been a lot quicker
to build an audience i can 100 say that
with confidence if i started it under my
name
shane parachutesgreat.com i'm telling
you that would have been that's the one
to do it final question man eliezer
yukowski tweeted this the other day and
it's amazing
such a good question if you're a
character in a book
what would your readers be yelling at
you to do
oh that's a great question um
what would they be yelling at me to do
probably
be more open about
working at an intelligence agency be
more open about stories
do more do more interviews this is what
people already yell at me to do
uh you know i keep i keep my profile
pretty low-key
for some of this and i would say do more
speak more in the podcast because i
don't talk a lot in our podcast and
um i think that that that's what i
already get yelled at so i would assume
that that just happened
to scale it up a bit and you know
um that's okay because that's not me
that's not what i wanted to do
so i just need to live a life that in
accordance with what i want and what i
value and
i'm doing things just to grow or get
myself
out there more that don't have another
purpose that aren't going to help our
mission
don't really help me well i'm glad that
you broke
the habit today and uh joined me fs.blog
uh where else should people go to check
out your stuff uh
at shane a parish p a p-a-r-i-s-h on
twitter
and uh if you just google shane parish
you'll you'll find a whole bunch of
stuff
and yeah would love for you to follow
along and
join us on our mission i love it man
thank you so much
thanks chris really appreciate this
thank you very much for tuning in
if you enjoyed that then press here for
a selection of the best clips
from the podcast over the last few weeks
and don't forget to subscribe
it makes me very happy peace
you